my name is Felix madhavi Agha I'm a
young global leader at the World
Economic Forum i am from nicaragua and i
want to address a question presented by
yacht vendor and yet has asked about
latin america has one of the highest
youth unemployment rates in the world
how can let merica increase
opportunities for young people yeah I
think this is a great question is a very
relevant question I come from one of the
areas in the world in which i use is the
majority in terms of the demographics
and distribution of the population but
in terms of opportunities in fact is the
population that has less access to jobs
less access to a full participation in
economics and their various dimensions
from which we can address this issue but
I would like to focus on a couple of
them the first interesting is education
I think that American steals lagging
behind the rest of the world in terms of
investment in education and it's not
only investment in in quantitative terms
but also in terms of relevance so let
merican countries need to develop
education policies that address the
needs of the market so the kind of
education that is being provided to use
is relevant to the demands of the market
and i think that's that's very important
and not only at the basic level but also
in technical education and of course at
university education the second issues
is in terms of comprehensive liberties
and opportunities to youth for example
access to health care access to
nutrition access to a citizen
participation that would allowed
citizens and particularly used to be
full participants in the economy and
food participants in developing other
communities this is a great question and
and it's an issue that is being
addressed at the different panels here
at the World Economic Forum on Latin
America thank you yet